okay we got ourselves an fm
never played jup before
how do you say it in spanish never mind
anyway we go d4 now we go for the
queen's garbage or
in this case the slav a6
haven't seen that one in a while
let's go for the move the cool kids play
huh queen c2
problem is i'm not a cool kid and i
don't know a lot about it
but that's not a worry e6 will go
e4 and here we'll take
take everything and i think in this case
black's just a tempo down
or a6 is a bit of a wasted tempo
normal positions let's just go to d5
here
i think that must be reasonable
the point is just to prevent c5 and
establish or and also prevent um
[Music]
prevent bishop b4 and just establish
a very good good structure for me now of
course
i'll happily i think
just exchange
no need even to castle queenside
but i'll just do it for
the lols i'll just exchange
i'll just castle queenside and then try
and attack
in general it was unnecessary because
i'm just positionally better
without without those complications
um yeah i can take b6
i think i'll do it
oh no oh no that's no good
i wanted to take queen cs6 and uh
take some knight e4 and i kind of
protect f2
that would that was a huge mistake
never mind we continue to play bishop c4
[Music]
but now it's uh it's a lot more
complicated
okay rookie one
[Music]
bishop six may be coming then we go
bishop b3
yeah this was really really poor
i really misplayed this but i i still
have a good position though
now i think i'm probably threatening to
take on c6
maybe still not really because there's
the bishop b7 at the end hitting g2
oh bishop b5
well sometimes when you're at you when
you ask for it you're gonna get it so
i'll sack a piece
[Music]
and try and break through
just looks very very tempting i think
there is
really little reason for my opponent to
think
this knight clearly needs to be captured
well i guess not takes rookie 6 king g7
rookie 7 king h6 queen d2
g5 h4 probably was mating so i can
understand but
still what my opponent did
seems to lose quite precisely
of course provided i can
i can keep keep up at least a
reasonable tempo here
but now just two pawns up with uh with a
great position
we'll offer an exchange of queens
um yeah queen c7 that was missed
knight f7 seems to be reasonable though
move the bishop away
bhp 2 will move the rook
g4 try and coordinate
just exchange that go f4 and turning d5
[Music]
we take on c6 just collecting everything
at this point
we'll go back collect one more pawn
c7
just keeping everything under control
and there's
there everything goes okay just a
second